UTILITY AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
MEETING WE ARE SHORT OF A QUORUM --
BUT WILL OPERATE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE UNTIL WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND TODAY WERE HERE IN THE SIM
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY SIX
BRADFORD.
SIR BRADFORD WELCOME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
FIRST LET ME SAY I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT AND I THINK
THE STAFF IN THE CHAIR.
FOR THEIR WORK IN THIS EFFORT --
AS YOU KNOW SB SIX SEVEN SIX IS
A COMMON SENSE BILL.
THAT JUST ENSURE THAT WE STARTED
DRESSING IMPACTS THAT ELECTRICAL
VI<c.cyan> VEHICLE CHARGER WILL HAVE --</c>
BY -- TWENTY TWENTY FIVE EVEY AT
PEAK CHARGING WILL DEMAND
EQUIVALENT OF A POWER -- ENTIRE
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT THE STATE
HAS BEEN DISCUSSING VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME AND IT'S TIME
THAT YOU KNOW WE STARTED
DRESSING APPROACH OUR PROBLEM.
THIS BILL DOES JUST THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE IN
A DAY WITH ME IT'S A REPRESENTED
FOR ME MOTOR WORKS WHO WILL GIVE
A STATEMENT AS WELL [inaudible]
MORNING.
AT YOUR HOLDEN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS TOPIC -- MY NAME'S DAVID
SCHLOSSBERG I REPRESENT A MOTOR
WORKS WERE AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATION MANUFACTURE AND
ENERGY SERVICES PROVIDER.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SEVEN SIX
WHICH WOULD CREATE A MARKET
TRANSFORMATION INITIATIVE FOR
VEHICLE GREATER GRATION SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN -- THE AMBITIOUS POLICIES
THAT WE HAVE IS A STATE WITH AN
ACTIVE OVER THE PAST DECADE TO
RAPIDLY TO CARBONIZED ARE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
VEHICLE GREAT INTEGRATION IS AN
ESSENTIAL IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING THAT THIS LARGE
INVESTMENT.
IS DONE IN A WAY THAT MAXIMIZES
ECONOMIC VALUE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BOTH EVEY DRIVERS
AS WELL AS THOSE NOT YET
ADOPTING.
BY ENSURING THAT THE INCREASE IN
DEMAND FOR MAYBE CHARGING IS
USED AND AS A LEASE COST
RESOURCE TO INTEGRATE OUR OUR
DISHES AND AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
TARGETS.
AND REDUCE AND TO ENSURE THAT
EVEN CHARGING PROVIDES NOT
BENEFITS FOR ALL REPAIRS AND
REDUCING COSTS -- SO THIS BILL
IS TIMELY AND IT'S ESSENTIAL
GIVE AN IMMENSE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT THE STATE IS
COMMITTED TO VEHICLE EDUCATION
AND CHARGING STATION DEPLOYMENT.
AS WELL AS THE TRANSITION WILL
SEE AN EASY MARKET OVER THE NEXT
DECADE AS WE MOVE FROM THOSE
EARLY ADOPTERS TO THE MASS
MARKET.
WITH EDIE'S A SECT ACCESSIBLE
FOR ALL.
THANK YOU FOR TALK.
THANK YOU WILL WELCOME ANY ONE
FROM THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE
TO ADD THEIR VOICES SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS TELE TRAINED ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT. TO THE PHANTOM HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY IN DEMAND
RECOUNTS ON SUPPORT.
BUT NOTHING GONZALEZ ON THE HAVE
A HYUNDAI NORTH AMERICAN SUPPORT.
NIKITA CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
BRING A CO THE ALLEGED VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SOLUTION ON BEHALF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES CESSATION WE
ACTUALLY HAD AN OPPOSING LAST
MINUTE POSITION BUT THE
AMENDMENTS ACCEPTED TODAY
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND WANTED
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF FOR SITTING DOWN WITH US.
LISTENING TO OUR ISSUES IN
RESOLVING THEM TODAY SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WE'LL NOW HEAR FROM ANYONE WHO'S
HERE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
SYRIAN -- NINE WILL TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SEE IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SAID WOULD.
MEMBERS LIKE TO MAKE CENTER WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED EFFORT
IN THIS AREA YOU KNOW WE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S STILL A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE.
ON THE TRANSPORTATION SIDE AND
THIS IS -- THE KIND OF
FOUNDATION IS IMPORTANT IN ORDER
WE'RE GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND
SEE OUR GOALS ACHIEVED.
A WE WILL TURN TO YOU IF YOU
HAVE ANY.
CLOSING COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SHARE WITH US AND THEN WE'LL
WAIT FOR A QUORUM WHERE WE CAN
AND TAKE ACTION ON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I
THINK YOU FOR THE KEPT
COLLABORATION WITH THE BOTH YOU
IN MERION -- MOVING TO SING FOR
CHIRLA AT THE PROPER TIME
WINTERKORN'S DOUBTS APPRECIATE
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] THREE
SHORT [inaudible] TEN THE
PARKING LOT [inaudible]
OUT OF THE ONES THAT.
SEC.
BUT HE ALWAYS WANTS.
TO EXACTLY EXACTLY.
CHECK.
ONE TWO T'S STILL TOO SHORT.
NO TO SHORT.
NO TEACHER
.
OKAY WE LOOK LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM LET'S -- HAVE THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
HOLDEN HERE BUILDING HERE
PATTERSON.
THE NEW YEAR [inaudible]
BURKE.
CARILLO CARILLO HERE CHEN XIN
HERE CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES
[inaudible]
CG -- CITY HERE [inaudible]
QUIRK HERE.
REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HERE TEEN.
AND AT WATER GARCIA.
PRESIDENT.
HEY WE WE HAVE A A DO PASS WITH
THE MINISTER BE TAKEN IN
COMMUNICATION CONVEYANCE THAT
WOULD BE THE MOTION WE'RE
SEEKING SO MOVED -- IF THERE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS TO
THE MOTION.
OF THE SENATOR HAS MADE HER A
CLOSING COMMENT WE APPRECIATE
THAT WE APPRECIATE AGAIN THE
GOOD WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING IN
THIS IS THE SPACE SO WILL.
A CALL THE ROLL ON THE MOTION.
SB.
SIX SEVEN SIX BEING THE MOTIONS
TO PASS WITH THE MINISTRY TO BE
TAKEN IN COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE SEE.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO HI CHEN.
GEN I CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
WATER GARCIA I MAYES.
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
NOT VOTING.
QUIRK DYING QUIRK I REYES.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE TEEN.
THAT'S TEN VOTES THE THE BILL IS
OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES FOR OTHER
MEMBERS. TO TO COME IN AND OUT
ON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITMENT FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU HAPPY FOURTH OF JULY.
YOU [inaudible]
TO SURE
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WHAT NOW -- OKAY -- WELCOME
ASSERTING WORK WILL GO BACK
THROUGH THE ROLE AND TAKE --
RECORD YOUR VOTE ON THE ITEM
REYES TEAM.
TING I
FIVE MINUTES WHAT
[inaudible]
YES.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE --
THIS ITEM SENATE BILL. SIX
SEVENTY SIX BRADFORD TO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS TO COMMUNICATION
CONVEYANCE.
REYES REYES REYES I OKAY AND
THAT HAS. 215-671-01112 TWELVE
OAKS THAT'S IT FOR TODAY THAT NO
ONE ELSE.
OF THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED